WAS IN FULL SWING,
BUT TO GAIN ENTRY
TO THIS EXCLUSIVE EVENT,
I'D NEED
AN AGE-APPROPRIATE ESCORT.
I DON'T HAVE A DATE MYSELF.
NO DATE TO THE PROM.
BUT JUST LIKE
WHEN I WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL,
EVERY TEENAGE GIRL I ASKED
ALREADY HAD PLANS.
THAT'S QUITE HURTFUL,
BUT THANK YOU FOR YOUR HONESTY.
EXCUSE ME, I DON'T HAVE
A VISITOR'S PASS,
SO I NEED TO MAKE THIS
REALLY QUICK.
HEY, I'M LOOKING FOR A DATE
TO YOUR SENIOR PROM,
AND I DON'T CARE
WHO I GO WITH.
HANG ON, NOW.
ALL RIGHT.
OOP, THERE'S THAT
GUIDANCE COUNSELOR
WHO WAS GIVING ME GRIEF
BEFORE.
I'M NOT SUPPOSED TO BE
IN THE BUILDING.
EVENTUALLY, MY SEARCH
FOR A HUMAN PROM TICKET
LED ME TO MY OWN LIVING ROOM.
I SEE YOU FOUND
THE SANDWICHES.
MEG CARMICHAEL, A SENIOR
AT NEARBY FRANKLIN HIGH,
WAS OUR SITTER.
[classical music playing]
♪
[music stops]
MEG, THERE'S SOMETHING I'D LIKE
TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT.
YOU'RE A SENIOR
IN HIGH SCHOOL NOW, YES?
- Y-YEAH.
- AND YOU'VE GOT A PROM
COMING UP, RIGHT?
- YEAH.
- HAS ANYONE ASKED YOU
TO YOUR SENIOR PROM YET?
- NO.
- HOW WOULD YOU LIKE
TO GO TO YOUR PROM WITH ME?
- OKAY.
- YES!
OH, GOODY!
I'M--I'M GLAD. I'M GLAD.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE
A VERY GOOD TIME.
NOW I'LL TAKE YOU HOME.
I ARRIVED AT 6:00 SHARP
TO FIND MY DATE LOOKING
ELEGANT AND LADYLIKE.
[chuckles]
LOOK AT THAT DRESS.
OH, MY GOODNESS, IT MATCHES
YOUR WHOLE PERSONALITY.
AFTER A BRIEF PHOTO SHOOT
ON THE FRONT LAWN...
THIS IS SORT OF AN EXCITING
MILESTONE
FOR PARENTS, ISN'T IT?
WHO KNOWS WHAT'S IN STORE
FOR US TONIGHT?
- WE WERE ON OUR WAY.